sure so look you know we're living
through probably the biggest medical
scandal today
is that there's a sudden spike in these
teenage girls
out of nowhere medically transitioning
all of a sudden they want hormones and
surgeries they're easily obtaining them
and um i wrote a book about it and
because
two twitter users decided the book was
transphobic
um they told that they called it that to
target target removed it
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report joining me today for a long
overdue
interview is author of the new book
irreversible damage
the transgender craze seducing our
daughters abigail schreier welcome to
the reuben report
thanks so much for having me on so the
book came out
in june and kind of caught fire in june
and then i was going to have you on in
august and i went off the grid
and then you know there was election
stuff so i didn't have yan and then a
couple weeks ago
all hell broke loose because target
tweeted that they were gonna no longer
carry the book so let's just start
with the controversy because actually
the reason i'm having you on
right now is that after the controversy
uh the book
absolutely sold out everywhere and we
had to hold this interview
so that the book would be stocked again
so a lot's going on so let's just start
with the controversy
first because the what you write about
here in the transgender craze
is really like the hot topic of the day
and the thing that seems to get the most
people in hot water so what happened
with target let's start there
sure so look you know we're living
through probably the biggest medical
scandal
today is that there's a sudden spike in
these teenage girls
out of nowhere medically transitioning
all of a sudden they want hormones and
surgeries they're
easily obtaining them and um i wrote a
book about it
and because two twitter users
decided the book was transphobic um they
told that they called it that to target
target removed it
and people were very upset you know the
book has a lot of grassroots support a
lot of parents feel like
it really explained the story of what
happened to them when their teenagers
suddenly out of the blue decided with
their friends that they were transgender
and they were really upset and a lot of
people wrote to target and target
you know reinstated it it was you know
you know
one of the few victories i think against
cancel culture
yeah you must have been pretty enthused
to see the amount of support that you
got
because yeah you get the usual twitter
haters and the anonymous accounts and
all that stuff
you know pushing target to a decision
like this but
but pretty much everybody that still
stands on the side of free speech i
guess we don't have that many people
anymore but
pretty much everyone that was around
supported you to get this thing back and
it actually did work
yeah i was very gratified look you know
there are literally
hundreds of books out there promoting
unskeptically the immediate medical
transition of teenagers
if you want to read that book there are
hundreds you can read and
and you know what i'm you know i i
certainly would never call for any of
them to be banned because i don't want
to live in that kind of world
but you know there is exactly one book
that did a deep dive into this
phenomenon
of teenage girls suddenly transitioning
and it's my book and for the activists
even one book is too many yeah okay so
let's start with
the most important conversa question
let's just get it out there right from
the top
abigail are you a transphobe do you have
an irrational
fear of trans people and is that why you
wrote this book
no i wrote the book first of all because
a reader wrote to me and she told me her
daughter had gone through this
phenomenon
and when she you know she said her
daughter had always been a girly girl
never had gender dysphoria this is
um severe discomfort and one's
biological sex but when she got to high
school she had a lot of mental health
issues and she went off to college
and with a group of girlfriends they all
decided they were transgender and
she started a course of testosterone and
i tried to find another investigative
journalist who would take it up
because i had you know i wasn't an
investigative journalist and i couldn't
find one
so after four months i finally got back
in touch with her and i said all right
i'll do it i mean that's
that's the world we're living in and let
me just say that a lot of transgender
adults and i interviewed a lot from my
book
support the book i mean the book does
not i'm not against medical transition
it just urges caution when it comes to
these teenage girls
okay so just to be absolutely clear and
i know my audience totally
understands it but so you don't have a
problem with
adults that transition that make the
choice in their lives to transition
no i mean not only am i not against it
i've interviewed a lot of transgender
adults i believe it has helped
um trans it can help um i i know them i
talk to them and i'll tell you something
else i'm not even against
all medical transition for teenagers the
only thing i
i show in the book is that the current
medical regime
has no medical judgment in place it's
totally based on the judgment of
teenagers
and the doctors are told to affirm
affirm a firm meaning they have to agree
with the teenager's self-diagnosis
so there's no checks in place so the
regime the current medical regime is
really not safe for teenage girls
yeah so i was trying to think how i
wanted to conduct this interview because
you know this is one of the topics that
we've touched on a bunch here not
because
i particularly care about these issues
as much as
when it's become such a hot button issue
then it sort of gets to my plate but i
thought i read the book
and i thought that the way that you laid
it out uh just
even in the chapters the way you
separated certain things was really good
so if you don't mind we'll just go
through chapter by chapter and and
discuss
each one so the introduction is about
the contagion
and that's sort of what you're hitting
on about what happened with uh with your
friend's daughter at college can you can
you describe that
sure so um it's based on the you know
research of lisa littmann as we'll talk
about the next chapter but um
the public health researcher who looked
into why there was a sudden and huge
spike in teenage girls
who claimed to have gender dysphoria and
this is not the population that
traditionally had it it was always
males and it usually began in early
childhood and all of a sudden across the
west
including america we have the sudden
spike of teenage girls deciding they're
transgender often with their friends and
often
after the encouragement of social media
influencers
right so you talk about this a little
bit later in the book so i'm jumping
ahead a bit but you tell a story of a
girl
who in essence in high school came out
as transgender
there weren't a lot of issues that she
was bringing up before that
but then suddenly she's getting more
likes on tumblr
she's now part of an oppressed minority
at school and in different groups
and that that allure basically and i
know i'm getting a little ahead of
ourselves here but but that allure in a
weird way
is what's fueling so much of this that's
right so it's young
teenage girls these are often white
middle or upper middle class girls
they're very precocious
but they are high anxiety and high
depression girls they have a lot of
mental health issues
and for the first time the moment they
get to high school and or in middle
school
and decide they're transgender you know
it's the first time they get so much
encouragement and love especially online
and sometimes from adults and and some
of these adults are not you know
are not up to very much good um but but
they get the showering of love and
praise
and they don't want to walk away from
that so chapter one which is about the
girls that you're describing right there
you know we've talked a lot about and i
think you know i was on tour with jordan
peterson for a year and a half and and
he focused
more so i would say on young men but it
was a message that obviously
traversed it didn't matter what gender
you really were but is there something
specific
going on with young girls that we're not
aware of like there does seem to be an
emasculation of young boys that we see
but what do you think is happening with
young girls right so
teenage girls specifically fall for
almost every one of these so-called
hysterias and the reason they do
is they tend to take on their friend's
pain if a young man is depressed very
often
his friend will say okay let's go play
basketball or
or suggest doing something but he won't
say what are you feeling
tell me about your pain and he won't
start to take it on himself he won't
agree with his friend
about how terrible life is just to make
his friend feel better
but we know and i interviewed a lot of
psychologists about this young women
tend to not only take on their friends
pain they're willing to distort reality
in order to make their friend feel
better um and and so that's why they
tend to you know all of these
you know um anorexia is spread this way
they tend to
you know take on whatever their their
friend's reality is
even if it's oh i'm too fat um whatever
won't they they think will make their
friend feel better they'll take that on
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about women's
issues instead of non-stop yelling check
out our women's issues playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell